hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for Monday May 28th May 28 2008 een
what's going on so i just had to cry it
out of me on the motorcycle oh Jesus ah
if only kids knew how to play basketball
these days and I'm actually talking
about the Cavaliers and the Celtics if
we just played basketball in the end we
just played basketball we actually could
I didn't think we went 1 2 games of that
series I was just like LeBron James is
LeBron James if we just [ __ ] play but
I didn't see one pick-and-roll that
whole [ __ ] game maybe I missed it I
mean I was having a couple as I was
sitting there just watching it it's Game
seven
you know stressing out it had to take
the edge off there you know I was
talking to a buddy of mine I swear to
God if you take a [ __ ] three-pointer
with nobody underneath and you miss that
should be in the stat sheet as a
turnover that's all I'm gonna say Jesus
Christ this is what happens when
everybody in the league is a [ __ ]
one-and-done guy you know they never
took a physics class or I don't know
ever [ __ ] had a ruler and [ __ ]
measured dude we would there was like
six minutes left we're like down by I
don't know four five six seven points we
just start taking threes every time we
go down the court like like there was
like five seconds left
like the crowd was counting down I don't
know having said that I got to tell you
right now LeBron James in my mind
leapfrog Kobe Bryant
taking that team to the NBA Finals I
just I just think Kobe would have been
too free he just didn't have that he
just didn't have that thing he would
just look at everybody on the bench like
the bums they were and be like what the
[ __ ] and would just walk into the front
office and be like I'm not playing with
this [ __ ] get me better guys or I'm
[ __ ] leaving that's that's how he got
his titles he was also a beast you know
I'm a Celtics fan so I always have to
[ __ ] on him a little bit you know what I
mean the Black Mamba he's ice cold
except when he was crying in the front
office Jesus bill can you stay on topic
sorry this has nothing to do with Kobe
Bryant East one of the greatest players
of all [ __ ] time right I'm just a
[ __ ] butthurt Celtics fan right now
whose team weigh over a chief so I said
I should be happy but LeBron James what
the [ __ ] that guy did Jesus Christ
unbelievable speechless I don't I don't
know what to say and from what I've
heard the Warriors are a little banged
up they got that game seven tonight so I
mean I guess you know as a fan of
basketball and more importantly
competition I have to root for the
Cavaliers or the Houston Rockets I mean
you just you can't root for a pile-on
team unless they're playing another
pylon team isn't that how it works and
admittedly the Celtics had won in 2008 I
didn't watch that team the whole year
you know I watched during the playoffs
then we played the Lakers I was like I
doubt pylon team versio pylon team
whatever I'll do it but our
congratulations congratulations to the
Cleveland Cavaliers LeBron James without
a doubt I mean you got it I mean I would
put that guy like I don't know it's hard
it's hard when you start talking Oscar
Robertson Bill Russell now I don't know
where the [ __ ] he is but he's past Kobe
and the modern
I'd have to say that it's him and Jordan
and I know a lot of you young kids right
now who didn't watch Michael Jordan you
know you go back and go on YouTube when
you watch his highlights and that type
that guy he literally changed the game I
can't I can't stress that enough like
the game changed
he didn't dominate the game the way Kobe
did he literally changed it like oh I
didn't know you could [ __ ] do that I
had no idea you could do that my only
knock against LeBron James is what he
[ __ ] blocked that shot and then just
stood there basking in his own amazing
amazing amazing Nisour whatever and then
the announcer Jackson goes every once in
a while sit so my every once in a while
you make a play that's so unbelievable
you have to stand there and admire it
and I was sitting there like the oldest
old man ever going like that that Yolo
[ __ ] yo I can't even believe how I
can't even believe how amazing I am you
know you can't really say to help out
your teammates he had a ball in his back
but just what the [ __ ] was he doing back
there standing there for like 20 minutes
like do you understand what that dumb
look on his face like he just stopped a
scud missile you blocked a shot I don't
know I am officially this is how old I
am okay this is hello I was actually
watching old school TV shows and like I
turned 50 next month as much as it's
[ __ ] with me I wouldn't change when I
was born to live now as a younger person
and I'm for this simple reason that when
I was a kid this is what a theme song
sounded like on a TV show
[Applause]
like a [ __ ] porno that's all people
playing it come on get to the [ __ ]
horns
[Music]
nice big boo-boo wipe what up you knew
somebody was getting [ __ ] up those
were all [ __ ] people you know
something after they played that theme
song they didn't stand in the studio
admiring what the [ __ ] they just did
other than that I love LeBron James I do
I'm just breaking his [ __ ] balls and
I also love the city of Cleveland and I
even still love the city Cleveland even
after about five or six thousand
Cleveland Cavaliers fans went at me
sending me [ __ ] all kinds of [ __ ]
over social media like like they weren't
they like they didn't have a Cleveland
steamer and their [ __ ] pants whatever
the [ __ ] I hate those stupid jokes by
the way you know a dirty sanchez you
know I don't and you keep the joke to
yourself it's all the same [ __ ] when
you stick your dick and [ __ ] and you
shove it up a nose and you go god bless
you but you say it in Spanish with water
bubbler jokes those are all jokes for
people who don't know how to make a move
right they just stand there hey this
one's cool can you [ __ ] play look
cool oh that gives me douche chills I
hate I always [ __ ] hated those jokes
anyways I like always to trash Patrice
when he used to do those jokes on stage
we Street you're doing street jokes
you're doing street jokes
anyways I'm all over the [ __ ] map
here sorry man I'm shaking off a game
seven loss yeah I was just psyched that
we got to these two Conference Finals
then all of a sudden psych holy [ __ ] we
could actually win this [ __ ] thing
then I'm like and if the Warriors lose
to the Rockets who gives a [ __ ] about
the Rockets we always beat the Rockets
in the file we beat him in 81 and 86
we're gonna have the trifecta Oh Billy
started dreaming anyways feels Cleveland
fans who were talking all this crazy
[ __ ] all right yeah you're lying to
yourself if you forgot about that Jason
Tatum dunk on LeBron James okay
that right there is what's known as the
changing of the guard okay that was like
the first time
Shaq started having problems with his
big toe like that's the beginning of the
end okay and a new chapters coming in
and it's dressed in green and white All
Right see but this one [ __ ] guy i
trashed him on twitter he gave me some
[ __ ] and he had a stupid
Cavaliers Jersey you know and his hat on
you know with this game seven look on
his face I said but he was wearing his
seat belt I don't know some Cleveland
fans when they look up in the rafters
and they start counting banners they
forget that an Eastern Conference
championship is not an NBA title
alright and a division title banner is
is literally that's like like that's
something you give to a millennial like
alright you did something I don't know
why Ali got like five people gave me
[ __ ] why why am i doing this right now
why am I being so childish oh god we
were right [ __ ] there we were right
there anyways and I'm not going to do
that dumb [ __ ] of like so it's always
there you won fair and square
everybody gets hurt LeBron's hurt right
he's probably all [ __ ] up from
carrying those people anyways
congratulations that really didn't sound
like a congratulatory [ __ ] in ten
minutes here but that's that's what I
was trying to get to congratulations to
Cleveland all right even like Eagles
fans started giving me [ __ ] it's just
like dude you know are you [ __ ]
serious right now
good lord the Philadelphia when did
Philly ever start talking [ __ ] about
sports this is what I want all you guys
to do what is the championship
combination to open your city count you
championships ours is five six eight 17
oh that unlocks to safe and all the rigs
pour out what happens in Philly Philly
is 2 to 3 1
go [ __ ] yourselves
you [ __ ] green [ __ ] you hang around
long enough you're gonna [ __ ] win one
that was another one this guy was giving
me [ __ ] on the Celtics won like 11
championships before there was anybody
it's like alright well since then we won
six stop talking about the Cavaliers
like they're an expansion team they've
been in the league for almost 50 seasons
[ __ ] Miami Heat showed up in 88
I think they've won more than the
Celtics whether they win one
they went for they've won four I don't
know why am i trashing cities I don't
want to try don't give a [ __ ] about
Philly I like Philly I like Cleveland I
like all of this [ __ ] I'm just [ __ ]
you know it still stinks that I lost I
suck I said I I wish I don't even
[ __ ] hate the Yankees anymore you
can't hate him they're all basically
they added one free agent other than
that several team it's just I think I
hate the Lakers the most just because I
live out here you know I'd say that was
yeah probably just cuz I live out here
and then Canadian fans but they just you
know chasing their own [ __ ] tails so
they don't even matter anymore I don't
know I guess I guess I'm just not mad
anymore
I mean I'm still mad but I guess it
probably is childhood issues wow why the
[ __ ] do I even watch sports all right
guys I'm gonna end this podcast and I
just had an epiphany
none of this matters um and he wasn't
[ __ ] with you goddamnit
Oh God Oh what game seven sting Game
seven loss stinks it really stinks jesus
[ __ ] christ I'm not gonna lie to you
I mean I haven't watched eunbi him so
long I know I watched the Celtics like
all last season I watched him and I just
I just cannot get over running down the
court and just [ __ ] stopping and if
your teammates haven't even settled and
just pulling up and taking a three and
just not getting yanked out of the
[ __ ] game the only thing that makes
that okay is the other teams are doing
it too
it's like watching this high skilled
like game at the YMCA you know there's
no plays everybody just met each other
you know you just [ __ ]
yep they're trying to burn calories all
right bill let it go okay I'll let it go
I'll let it go how badass is that
[ __ ] theme song it's from the streets
of San Francisco by the way I've been
trying to find the original one but I
can only best I can find is the Henry
man sees Mancini version of it that was
the heyday of the white cop chasing the
minority actor down the street and the
only role that he was going to get that
decade you know they should they should
go back and they should do a documentary
on all those [ __ ] guys you know like
who has the record like what black actor
in the 70s had the record for the most
times he did a scene what he was running
down an alley being chased by the cops
you know when you get to the fence
that's the scene I always wanted to do
you get to the chain-link fence you get
like you know a couple of rungs up and
then they grab your back you're like now
if I could drag you off will you go in
freckles
you know hurry or something sorry not
going nowhere
[Laughter]
[Music]
anyways congratulations and other
congratulations I'm just I'm just being
this is me in a very generous thankful
mood it's Memorial Day right thanking
the troops people that made the ultimate
sacrifice you know it's a bit of a drop
off to thank a [ __ ] professional
basketball team after you thanked the
troops but uh you know congratulations
to Daniel Ricciardo winning his first
race Formula One race in Monaco how
about that that's the race I want to go
to and it's probably the most boring f1
race because that race is all about
qualifying that's the race whoever
[ __ ] wins the pole position I mean
they're racing in those little ass
[ __ ] streets you know what I mean you
know why those streets are so small over
there it's not because the city's so old
and used to just ride a horse down it's
because that's a sovereign city and
that's Illuminati money and they like
their [ __ ] skinny
they like him young and thin okay so
that's that's they'll lock the door test
if they can walk down the street with
that day hips touching either building
then they'll have their current wife
disposed of I think that's what they do
and then they stay young evidently
somebody sent me this [ __ ] thing in
here I think this is how they stay young
somebody wrote to me said foreskin
injections yo bill what gives in
Hollywood
my girlfriend show showed me a video of
an actress on Ellen talking about
injecting for skin cells imported from
Korea Koreans circumcisions
sorry into her face to look young get
out of there bill we can't have you
injecting dick skin into your face for
roles the [ __ ] going on what do you
mean what the [ __ ] is going on we are
the leaders of how to stay young out
here in Hollywood okay what do you think
your Rogaine came from what do you think
your your Grecian formula is gonna come
from huh what do you think all your
workouts come from they come from
Hollywood all your fad diets that's us
okay we came up with all of that you
know why because you [ __ ] are always
trashing us you hold us to a higher
standard okay you look to us to see what
the future of vanity is you look to us
to make it okay okay Botox started out
here now look it's all over the country
you're all [ __ ] doing it all these
real [ __ ] housewives huh you all made
fun of us and now look at you you're all
on steroids you get in the [ __ ] good
hair plugs because people out here in
Hollywood you know had the decency to
stick those an't legs into their [ __ ]
heads to let these doctors make mistakes
with their own face until it becomes
safe enough that you could sneak into
some [ __ ] back alley and get the same
procedure done to you when you start
getting your man tits all right sir how
dare you make fun of Hollywood
thanks to our self-involvement you'll be
able to wear a tank top well into your
60s you're welcome sir I mean I don't
know who's more [ __ ] arrogant
Cleveland Cavalier fans talking [ __ ]
like they own the NBA when all they ever
do is show up in the finals to be the
Washington Generals
except that one year when they want or
you regular [ __ ] people who sit there
going these [ __ ] celebrities they
need to be taken down a peg and yadda
yadda yadda [ __ ] yada let me tell you
something they're grill master now give
to their Foreman grill or whatever type
of [ __ ] cookery you have in your
goddamn kitchen huh with your little
[ __ ] makeover in your sad little
[ __ ] house you know and then you turn
on the TV to see what a dream looks like
and who's standing there me and my bald
[ __ ] head by the way I'm not gonna
lie to you guys for my 50th birthday I
think I'm gonna give myself hair plugs I
think I've earned them okay I'd like to
brush my teeth you know and not stare at
the sink okay I would like to look up
and see something that I like and you
know I just want to live my truth you
know that's all that I'm doing and hey
you know if hair plugs are gonna make me
feel better then I say I should do it
and you know something I think it's time
that I gave myself permission to look
sexy again why in the [ __ ] would you
ever like I could see if you had
American for skin cells all right but
like why would you get four skin cells
imported from a country that we're
really not getting along with at least
not half of it you know why don't you
just get Botox from China it's probably
weights from right
said mate from China said yeah people
are out of their [ __ ] minds
I am doing my damnedest to stay in shape
but I'm going to age [ __ ] naturally
that's it you know I mean other than the
I get a varicose vein in my left leg you
know that looks like a goddamn road map
to [ __ ] Albuquerque you know I might
get that taken at some point I keep
meaning to get around to it but I never
wear shorts you know because I respect
people you know all these fatties out
there wearing half shirts
acting like they're brave you're not
you're disgusting and everybody should
point you like we're in an invasion of
the body snatchers okay I don't care
that you're fat but you know you put on
put on a whole shirt maybe it is a whole
shirt maybe you just ate so much that
now we can see you belly again you know
like you ever see a woman with big tits
wearing a half shirt and then when you
turn around to look at her it goes all
the way down to her ass in the back and
it's like oh that's not a half shirt she
just has giant tits she can't help it
she can't help it it's not her fault
anyways I took my daughter we went out
for a walk today and we went up we went
on a hike and you know I was pushing the
stroller the whole way up what a great
workout man you go up the [ __ ] hills
pushing a stroller you know feel it's an
extra 25 pounds right there
just pushing it up pushing it up the
goddamn hill I saw this guy I can with
his daughter and his son is they got a
little old I thought it was really cool
it's like man I'd love to do that
someday you know although his son was
still wearing his pajamas I was just
like come on man you gotta tell him put
his clothes on but then I was thinking
like yeah I lose my favorite pajamas and
I would have caved - all right all right
all right son
now I would and I bet all right well we
wear them in the house all right then
we're not going I can well join the club
son join the club
I really don't even know what the [ __ ]
I've been talking about I'm just trying
to fill up time here that's all I do
here in this park
if you new to it I'll tell you right now
I've never been so offended in my life
that someone actually has the audacity
to make fun of the vanity of Hollywood
and the Boston Celtics from two of the
most simple combination championship
combination cities ever what is
Cleveland Cleveland is zero the Indians
won in 48 I'll throw another one in
there
let me they [ __ ] wouldn't that's like
they're like 0 1 2 you know when it
comes to Championships I swear to God
there should be a fisher-price tag
hanging off the ones in Cleveland I'm
saying your children when it comes to
success up bill well why would you go
back into that bucket I hate cuz it's
gay it's fine I must use the line from
Brett dawn it keeps me warm all that
aids gonna burn you up keeps me warm
powers Boothe was it powers but was
power powers Boothe in that thing
what a [ __ ] name powers Boothe you
guys see Morgan Freeman got in a little
bit of trouble this week you know nobody
said how [ __ ] cool it is then an 80
year old guy could still [ __ ] you know
to me I mean that why can't we look at
the bright side of sexual harassment you
know plus he's 80 I mean what do you
think he's gonna do
I mean you stop listening to music a
couple years after high school you get
married you have a kid you don't know
what the [ __ ] going on this guy
doesn't know what's going on what do you
do next make fun of the playlist on his
flip phone he's in his [ __ ] 80s oh my
god I was so afraid I was so afraid when
that guy pushing a hundred that clip
where he was saying I wish I was there I
thought he was making fun of Michael
Caine going I wish I was there when you
stuck your foot in your mouth saying are
you pregnant and the woman wasn't that's
how I took it
I have no idea but what would I know
what would I know about male and female
relationships okay what the [ __ ] would I
know what was I looking up again
okay Cleveland the Cleveland Indians
this is such a [ __ ] thing to do after
they just had success to talk about
their entire pastures but this is all I
this is what she listened to is a sad
pathetic man taking swings at people who
are no longer in the room they've moved
on Cleveland Indians I want to I want to
coin that what is it what is your your
combination what Cleveland Indians World
Series champion chips and I put it
plural out of respect
World Series titles too so they got two
World Series one NBA zero Super Bowls
and we'll give them the [ __ ] Columbus
Blue Jackets with zero Stanley Cups so
the combination to Cleveland is zero
zero one two all right do you understand
we've won more Super Bowls than you know
why am i doing this this is so Chuck as
it's fun I'm not doing it to all
Cleveland I'm just doing it to the
[ __ ] how do you only went to Super
Bowl I mean to World Series and you have
like 58 retired numbers would you retire
the numbers for having the [ __ ]
jumping on the grenade and joining that
franchise ow bell
I like the Cleveland Indians you know it
really is I kind of just had a great
weekend and I don't really have anything
to talk about
oh by the way did anybody see the
highlight I I don't know what I did I
tried to favorite the thing on my
Instagram page which by the way I've
suck at it like I'm not making these
stupid videos goin the grocery store the
[ __ ] up with cantaloupe check me out
at the San Jose improv did you see that
[ __ ] guy MotoGP race where that
[ __ ] guy
I can't even describe what basically
he's thick they're all coming around the
corner they're all two inches from each
other one guy wipes out okay and his
bike lands perpendicular to the guy
behind him all right and the guy just
hits the gas and drives up over it like
a [ __ ] stuntman he's going 100
something miles an hour he goes flying
through the [ __ ] air and then lands
on gravel
and somehow saves it and doesn't go down
and continues on oh and by the way like
it's air bag pot I don't if you ever
seen those guys when they get off the
bikes after they wipe out their arms
looking weird like then like they're in
these weird you know when somebody gets
knocked out in their arms kind of going
they kind of stick out they do that a
little bit I'm guessing that's because
the air bag popped and they can't bring
their arms back down
this guy's air bag popped making him
less aerodynamic he continued to ride
the race this is [ __ ] it's badass
badass you know what I miss I missed the
[ __ ] Indy 500 after interviewing
Danica Patrick who by the way was so
[ __ ] badass and I think it's really
cool that she's retiring you know
retire well you still have some years
left you know it doesn't look you know
you don't a limp out of the league like
[ __ ] you know Brett Favre you know I
don't really think of those last few
years but it's just like dude you're in
there you're a Hall of Famer you one of
the greatest ever what are you doing you
want to get out before then and then
she'll say like a vineyard or something
like that it's really that's the way to
do it that's the way to get out of
showbiz you know I think The Smothers
Brothers did that like they didn't even
announced their retirement they from
what I heard I was working in Vegas they
did their last show at the Orleans
casino didn't say it was the last show
just said thank you good night and just
[ __ ] went retired to their vineyard
how [ __ ] bad I mean that is that's
that's it
like what Jordan hit that last shot as a
bull Smothers Brothers didn't come back
to play for them [ __ ] wizards
alright so Celtics lost at Game seven
and I am in the last days of my 40s I am
basically sitting here with a bottle of
tampons and some Kleenex this is this is
the end of it man you know I mean Jesus
I I look really good for [ __ ] 50 I'm
not gonna lie but I'm gonna tell you
right now nobody looks good at 60 okay I
don't give a [ __ ] what you do when
you're 60
you are 60 and all even though that's
not true
Kenny Aronoff did my podcast he looked
[ __ ] unbelievable
and he was a little north of 60 alright
that's it Kenny era Kenny Aronoff now
the guy I'm looking at alright
the day that guy falls off whatever
[ __ ] year that is I may be like God
now that's officially you [ __ ] old
right there you go
anyways let me be a little bit of
advertising here [ __ ] all over the
goddamn map oh look who it is indogene
Oh Oh steak steak looks greatness
sixties talk about how a made-to-measure
suit fits compared to a generic
off-the-rack suit well unless you the
size of a [ __ ] mannequin yeah this
again there's gonna be some problems was
that good endo cheeto is the world's
largest made to measure menswear company
and has been featured in major
publications including GQ Forbes on and
Fast Company Fast Company's at about
[ __ ] guys love the wide selection of
high quality and the option to
personalize all details including your
Appel outlet your lapel alright that's
[ __ ] cool lining and monogram
old-school [ __ ] you get your initials
put on the sleeve come on
here's how it works visit a showroom or
a shop online in a Tendo Chino calm pick
your fabric choose your customizations
submit your measurements wait for your
custom suit to arrive in just a few
weeks you got to do that that's [ __ ]
cool this week my listeners can get any
premium Indo cheeto suit for just 379
bucks at indochina calm when entering
per be you are are at checkout that's
50% off the regular price for a made to
[ __ ] measure premium supe plus
shipping is free
that's endo cheeto comm promo code bar
for any premium suit for just three
hundred $79 and free shipping incredible
deal for a suit that will fit you better
than anything off the rack ever could
all right what do we got oh my god
Dollar Shave Club dude dude you have a
shower a brush your teeth to try to make
you Hey
look presentable hey here's some good
news
Dollar Shave Club has a lot of stuff to
help you out the ugly bastard
dollar shape the ugly smelly bastard
this is that copy Shmi listen Dollar
Shave Club knows there's a lot of ugly
smelly bastards out there trying to get
a piece of pie you know you want to stop
looking so ugly and smell a little
better go to Dollar Shave Club
yes that's Dollar Shave Club it delivers
everything you need to look feel and
smell your best you name it shampoo
conditioner body wash toothpaste hair
gel hey gel even a wipe that'll leave
you a touch feeling tingly clean you'll
be a big fan you know you know what
those one wipe Charlies are though aheri
oh sorry
those are the [ __ ] that's the poor
man's bidet I gotta get some of those
you know who doesn't want their ass
feelin so fresh and so clean you'll be a
big fan of their amber and lavender
calming body cleanser after you try it
the first time when you drugging
yourself [ __ ] roofie
good luck finding a product that great
at the store all Dollar Shave club's
products are made with the top shelf and
Greve ingredients that won't break your
budget you'll feel that difficult they
got Grey Goose vodka in this soap plus
shipping is included with your
membership I actually like Belvedere
better and here's a great way to try a
bunch of Dollar Shave Club products for
just 5 bucks you can get their daily
essential starter set this is for men
honey have you seen my daily essential
starter set it comes with body cleanser
one wipe Chari
they're amazing butt wipes their
world-famous shave butter and their best
razor the six blade executive keep the
blades coming for a few bucks more a
month and add in shampoo toothpaste or
anything else you need speaking of your
next month for a limited time only use
the code burr at checkout to get five
dollars off your second month of the
club
that's code bar at dollarshaveclub.com
to save five dollars on your second
month join the club
stamps.com lastly but not leastly the US
Postal Service is an important tool for
any business buying print official US
postage for any letter any package any
class of mail using your own computer
and printer
stamps.com makes it easy like that girl
up the street to they'll send you a
digital scale automatically calculates
exact postage stamps comm will even help
you decide the best class of mail based
on your needs no need to lease an
expensive postage meter and there are no
long term commitments no way lady I use
stamps com any time I send out my
[ __ ] pulses I'm a [ __ ] if I can
figure it out so can you include your
personal recommendation I just did
absolutely no negative references to the
post office oh and right now you too can
enjoy the the stamps.com service with a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus postage and a digital scale
why can't I trash your competition the
post office maybe this is the post
offices sidepiece you know this is how
they're gonna gracefully get out of the
business I don't know was that negative
it wasn't negative it's just speculation
go to stamps.com click on the microphone
at the top the homepage and type in Berg
that's stamps.com and tuber
alright podcast is gonna be a little
little short this week everybody you
know it's gonna be just like that guy in
taxi you know know what's up what is the
[ __ ] show there the [ __ ] so he's
sunny in philadelphia spacing on the
guys name
he was Olsen in One Flew Over the
Cuckoo's Nest he was in kindergarten cop
no he wasn't he was in twins he was in
Romancing the Stone I think keep
thinking alan alda [ __ ]
drunk on that talk show was hilarious
louis de palma you know i'm talking
about anyways uh re-read the foreskin
injections wine country advice a billy
Barolo breath heard you talking to
Danica Patrick about why you said you
and Nia want to do a wine country trip
thought I'd give you some ideas I grow
grapes and make wine for a small
producer in Sonoma County and have been
in the wine industry for ten years
alright you have established credibility
why can't you just tell me where the
[ __ ] to go rather than read me your
entire resume you self-involved jackass
I'll sue before this guy has [ __ ]
Korean for skin cells injected into his
[ __ ] gray teeth make his teeth white
again after all that Merlot I am not
drinking Merlot I guess that [ __ ] up
the the whole Merlot industry I like
Merlot first of all don't do Napa its
douchey as [ __ ] honestly you only need
to drive a couple hours into Santo y Nez
Valley for an awesome weekend of wine
tasting they have all kinds of great
wines there but if you guys do want to
come all the way up to the quote real
wine country I really do think Sonoma
County is better than a peak Napa County
the mistake people make is going to the
actual town of Sonoma which is boring
and pretty shitty the move is to stay in
Hell's dude you're hooking me up
Helzberg which is in northern Sonoma
County [ __ ] loads of excellent tasting
rooms and restaurants just walking
around town plus tons of other wineries
nearby to drive to slash hire a car Napa
is only an hour away at most so you
could always cruise over there for a day
if there are some specific Napa wineries
you want to check out if ok if there's
some specific ones you wanna check out
but seriously [ __ ] Napa blown up way
over price wide most of them which
aren't great and they can't even grow
Pinot Noir over there it's too hot and
Pinot is the best wine there is once you
learn to notice and appreciate the
little
details bonus fact les claypool has a
winery here
he makes Pinot because he knows what's
up I [ __ ] love les claypool shape
baby do you want to [ __ ] drink wine
with me other football leagues well
thank you sir I'm gonna [ __ ] copy and
paste that and send that to my laughs
and see what she says our other football
leagues hey Williams just one you know
what I missed a Liverpool Cup final I'll
have to catch their next game next
season evidently I don't even know one I
would think Liverpool won I lost because
I didn't get any [ __ ] hey dude I hope
you watched your adopted team 1
Liverpool Cup final geez against Madrid
where the [ __ ] is it over here why is my
cable so slow not cable my internet come
on you [ __ ] oh come on come on why well
I don't [ __ ] up well you don't
evidently my computer is allergic to
soccer ok other football leagues hey
Williams shivers was wondering since
Johnny Manziel has made the switch if
you ever watch any CFL I love this CFL
CFL is so [ __ ] underrated CFL is
better than college football that's a
bunch of college all-stars that weren't
quite good enough to make it to the NFL
but what where any college football team
bigger field it's exciting I don't know
what the [ __ ] going on and there's
only like six teams right the Edmonton
Eskimos they're like your Washington
Redskins right if they get in pressure
to change that name
the Calgary Rough Riders the the BC
Eagles or as a Calgary Stampede right
isn't the Winnipeg nostril stickers
something like that some about the cold
weather out there I don't [ __ ] know
oh by the way tonight's the first night
of the Stanley Cup Finals right Stanley
Cup final not the NBA Finals
cup final in congratulations to the
[ __ ] Vegas Knights and the Washington
Capitals that's going to be exciting to
see either team win but I'm really
pulling for the Capitals I'm a big I'm a
big fan of [ __ ] what's-his-face there
that you can you know Russian players
get a bad name in the NHL
because I guess a number of them could
give a [ __ ] about winning a Stanley Cup
you know it was that guy that sign you
know was [ __ ] amazing played for the
Atlanta Thrashers got a giant contract
with New Jersey was just like yeah you
know I just don't give a [ __ ] and he
left went back to play hockey and uh
Russia like the Stanley Cup does like
that's the stereotype that it doesn't
mean [ __ ] to these guys all right so
guys like you know Malkin and in no vege
can got to bear the the the carry a load
of these other Russian [ __ ] that I
guess didn't give a [ __ ] so I'm rooting
for that guy
you know Trump probably wouldn't like it
that I'm rooting for a Russian but I
want to see him I want to see him win
one we should we shall see but what's
his face Vince Neil motley crue one of
my favorite groups of all time he's out
in Vegas and he's become a big [ __ ]
Vegas nights fan so no matter what I'm
gonna be happy whoever wins anyways
other football leagues I would
absolutely watch the CFL the biggest
difference is our field is longer long
and wider with bigger end zones and
field goal posts are on the goal line
we also function on a three down system
I'm probably a poor source for the rules
but hey I'm just some jackass right near
the podcast well let me know when it
starts PS you should see a SAS cast
Rouen Rough Riders game we are
considered one of the best football fan
bases around and do a show in Saskatoon
while you're at it go [ __ ] yourself and
have a lovely day I did I did a show
that's how I know you guys go I did a
show in SAS SAS got you one I did one in
Saskatoon and Regina the city that
rhymes with fun I never need to hear
that again I'll definitely be back it's
[ __ ] God's country up there and you
can see the Northern Lights like all
year round
boyfriend found out I cheated on my
ex-husband oh boy
Billy babushka lips what the [ __ ] is
babushka I got to look that up
Liverpool quest for glory ends in tears
as gareth bale wonder goal breaks heart
oh no oh I had enough sports pain for
the [ __ ] weekend what happened I'm
clicking on the link why won't you do
anything all right
was I looking at babushka it's one of my
favorite words of all time how do you
know what it means
Oh Billy babushka if I was a wrestling
manager that would be my name all right
should I end my relationship my
boyfriend of a year-and-a-half found out
I cheated on my ex-husband he's not
being a huge dick about it just
passive-aggressive whenever [ __ ] goes
down which is not too often he's a
little bit he's a little on the
sensitive side but until he found out
about my past that's what I liked about
he's a math computer guy not an alpha
male well you know you get what you pay
for sweetheart he does not care what
people think about him and he has a
unique sense of humor his family
definitely has mental issues his dad
refused to stay on dialysis and died
when he was in high school and two older
brothers off themselves when he was a
sophomore and a senior in college
Jesus [ __ ] Christ you datin the
Hemmingway's here I'm in my mid 30s and
have a good job he's two years older and
has a great job owns a house in a good
neighborhood no kids involved our
relationship is the best I've ever had I
feel a lot of love recently though after
he found out I sense a lapse he never
wants to talk about it I could never
imagine myself cheating again
I got married to my ex too young but now
that my baby-making years are coming to
an end I don't know what to do should I
stick around to see if we get back to
where we were or move on
go drink yourself yeah I don't [ __ ] you
know I don't know I don't know just be
like look I ever gonna be able to get
just ask him you gotta be able to get
past this
you know here's the thing you know yeah
you did do it
so he gives you [ __ ] you kind of got a
roll with it I guess
I have gives a [ __ ] yeah I just roll
with it for a little bit and just see if
old [ __ ] sensitive sense at all there
I know people always say that you know
if you [ __ ] cheat you're gonna cheat
again I don't know it all depends on
where you are in your life who the [ __ ]
you're with I don't know about that one
is there been a study on that I have no
idea I honestly don't know what to tell
you man
maybe you could turn it into some sort
of math joke dating older women dear
Billy blue balls my name is Prince I am
23 and about to be 24 in about a month I
am in a relationship with a 44 year old
woman yeah this is easy get the [ __ ] out
of it you're not in a relationship you
banging a 44 year old woman now I know
what you are thinking mommy issues much
no and I don't end [ __ ] sentences
with the word much nonetheless I just
said hey that's too much I don't know
some [ __ ] I hate that
something-something much you know what
else is when I hate so-and-so and then
something in quotes me something in
quotes and you're always the cool
[ __ ] person bill you're old get over
it people talk differently now all right
remember when you were young and
everybody would yell not
you think that was annoying to older
people all right you got me
now I know what you are thinking okay
now I know what you're thinking mommy
issues much yet that is part of the
reason I am with her if I'm being honest
well there you go
gotta love honesty we have been dating
for about five months now and things are
good but there are things that irritate
the hell out of me look what her [ __ ]
silver pubic hair like she thinks some
of my views on life and other things are
odd I honestly just think it's because
she grew up in a totally different time
yeah it's called a generation gap if you
get your face out of her gap and look at
the [ __ ] calendar sorry we have been
dating for about five months now and
things are good no they're not but there
are things that irritate I read this
they're not good sir you need to get the
[ __ ] out of this this is not going to
end well at some point you're gonna want
to have a kid all right
and if Regina is going to be in a
[ __ ] museum anyways where the [ __ ]
wasn't something that's definitely
different time than me but some of it
is that she isn't into science oh she
better be if she's going to try to keep
herself young like we got into an
argument about high-fructose corn syrup
because she said it's only sugar until I
proved to her that it's not just sugar
and she thinks that's not really science
yeah I thought you were into science
you're just reading facts that
scientists figured out that's not
science right I mean I could lay me the
fact that I could look that up and just
go here it is that's not scientist if I
can figure it out it's not science sir
and she thinks my fear of chemicals in
our food is odd as well it's hard being
with someone that doesn't get me another
thing in a another thing in a blackmail
oh I'm a black male and she's a white
female so she doesn't really understand
how it is to be a black man in this day
and at jesus-fucking-christ sir how many
red flags do you need you know
and she's she got fired from the police
department for dropping the n-word other
than that I think I really like her sir
what the [ __ ] you doing I'm gonna keep
going here and a jump taught and to jump
topic sex with her is good but it's like
we only have sex once and it sucks she
says it's because I leave her too so
okay I'm not I leave her to soar you
know is there anything worse than a big
[ __ ] dick nincompoop I I can't
[ __ ] oh yeah what am I supposed to do
with you sir
you and your porno [ __ ] need to [ __ ]
date somebody uh you know from from
she's almost twice your age and she
listens to cut you this is such a [ __ ]
up email I don't believe it
I'm calling [ __ ] on that one you
kind of did a slow roll on me you had me
you had me you had me and then you said
I'm black and I got a big dick Angie so
I don't believe it
I don't believe it maybe it's true
because I want to have excitement and
[ __ ] in our relationship and she just
doesn't bring that to the table I like
her a lot and we watch documentaries
together I'm sure does she fall asleep
halfway through it like I do anyways
all right okay and she has a venereal
disease but you know other than that you
know we laugh a lot
[ __ ] all right do we have anything
else here is there anything else that
needs to be discussed other than why is
my computer that I got kicked off line
you know and now Ethel would be funny if
I never got in the internet again and
the last thing I did was I looked up
babushka all right people it's Memorial
Day who's kidding who you're not [ __ ]
working today either all right I have to
go to a picnic
a kid picnic and I can't wait you know
what I actually got a great book here it
says 88 great daddy/daughter dates I
think I'm gonna do most of these you
know I got all these books you know a
dad's prayer for his daughter's daughter
that's [ __ ] weird
strong father's strong daughters 10
secrets every father should know
alright let's read a little bit of this
see how much disagree protect her defend
her okay
she needs oh my god hopefully this is
like alright how dumb would you have to
be to read this [ __ ] book ok 1 you
are the most important man in her life
chapter 2 she needs a hero chapter 3 you
are her first love chapter 4 teacher
humility oh she shouldn't stand there
like a LeBron James after you just
blocked a shot
protect her defend her and use a shotgun
if necessary pragmatism and grit your
two greatest I'll read that chapter
because I don't know what either one of
those means I know one of them was a
John Wayne movie be the man you want her
to marry gross teacher of who God is
gross teacher to fight that's right
there you go keep her connected
afterward acknowledgments bibliography
notes index I don't know what those last
six chapters were about let's see let's
read the chapter we'll start with index
here let's see what the hell I'm
supposed to tell my daughter a abortion
12 abstinence comma 1 13 - 1 14 this
doesn't make any sense
add health study ADHD advertising
african-americans this book is all over
the place
african-americans and that says
depression and STDs AIDS well why did
you have to drag black people into this
alcohol this is a weird chapter
I don't think I like this book I know
that I don't know who wrote one anyways
Oh [ __ ] Billy burger face is gonna go
[ __ ] and turn on the grill make a few
here this is one of my last podcast in
my 40s this is so stupid I'm turning 50
I'm not going to feel any [ __ ]
differently
I'll definitely go to try to eat better
then I've been doing that for the last
three months and I was FaceTime with
somebody and they were like - have you
lost weight and I was like not really I
was excited
so anyways I think that's it right
anything I'm doing a drum do my double
bass drum it's coming along it's coming
along
you know working on that song I had to
behold uh I had a bull hold of little
Metallica oh and I played streets of San
Francisco it's all serendipity all right
this is this is it I'm dumb done I'm not
gonna just [ __ ] me and her for
another [ __ ] six minutes just to say
I did it once again I apologize everyone
in Cleveland and in Philly for being a
[ __ ] all right you want a Super Bowl
congratulations you go in the NBA Finals
congratulations I hope you [ __ ]
cheesesteaks and whatever the [ __ ] it is
you guys eat there and cleave and I hope
they taste extra better today extra
special all right I'm off to watch some
baseball